not really a sports guy but they put up
some cool ads so I didn't watch the
super bowl cut it's not my thing if you
watch it hope you had a good time
watching it or if you didn't care for
the outcome my sympathies anyway I'm
going to talk about the trailers that
showed during the Super Bowl and I'm
going to talk all of them because I
don't think I have enough thoughts about
any of them then justify their own video
so these are going to be quick
impressions general thoughts on all the
trailers that hit I'm not going to have
this in any particular order so we'll
start with life now in the case of both
this and one of the one later there was
the shorter Super Bowl spot there was
also a longer version of the trailer
that premiered online and I watched both
and if I talk about stuff that was only
in the longer version apologies but
that's that mean that's just a second my
mind so life is you know the set in
space and it's got Ryan Reynolds and
it's been you know they find this first
hint of life on Mars and then everything
starts going horribly wrong and right up
until the point where it became clear
that the life-form was going to try and
kill them all they had to stop it from
reaching earth I was intrigued but as
soon as it hit that point I'm like that
feels real generic that could be that
could be on the SyFy channel for all I
don't care which is a shame because the
production values look good i actually
think space is a really great setting
for horror I just I kind of wish that it
hadn't kissed his hand and as much as
the trailer did I kind of wish that had
just been more like whoa the things
growing really rapidly and just gone for
something much more vaguely ominous as
opposed to having it just halfway in the
trailer really jack up to all I've been
sharing through everything I was like I
didn't want to know before going to see
the movie that it was going to get to
that level would have been nice to not
be sure how how dire was going to get so
I'm kind of now not interested in it
because i think the trailer showed too
much so the other one that had an
extended version online as was the
shorter version i was for the new
transformers which is transformers 5 the
first night the last night knights of
the old republic and something i don't
know but any case I just kind of don't
care the trailer didn't look
uninteresting but the thing is most
trailers for the Transformers movies at
least look fairly decent I've only ever
seen the first transformers and I didn't
love it I didn't hate it either i mean
the honest truth is I never got into
transformers one of the kids so I didn't
really care enough about the French has
one way or the other I saw the first one
was like as is okay and then having
heard from everybody since then though
the first one is the best one was like
if I wasn't impressed with the best 1
i'm not going to come back and so I
haven't you enjoyed these movies great
hope you have a fun time next up a cure
for wellness now I'm I am curious and
intrigued and hopeful on this one I love
the sense of atmosphere I think there's
some really good performers in it but
it's the kind of sort of interesting
setup that I think could really go off
the rails when it comes to the
explanation yes it's a setup that could
either have really fascinating answers
are really that was dumb one then that's
the risk you kind of run when you build
something around a really intriguing
mystery Gore Verbinski sort of going
back to horror a little bit looks like
God which she hasn't really done since
or the ring and I do like some of his
work on me he's had kind of a bad run
lately I it looks like this had a
smaller budget than he's been granted in
his last couple of movies that he's done
I think that might be good for him he
might do one of those guys were you give
him the freedom to do anything and he
just kind of loses discipline a little
bit so and this is what I'm intrigued by
guardians of the galaxy two now that now
this is a trailer that got me pumped
great use of P remove music again maybe
not quite as iconic as that good joke oh
good but you know I I mean I I love
Fleetwood Mac so I love that song anyway
but I thought it was a great song I love
that we get glimpses of all the
characters I we get a couple of great
great laughs OH Drax I forgot how funny
he is but I love the look I love the
feel I love I that I mean that first
movie is such a good time that I just I
can't I i was already excited to space
up how much i love the last one and I
see the show my yes that is basically
everything I like last time around and
possibly more of it so i will i'll take
that i am happy
I'm pumped next up Logan now this one
kind of didn't really do anything for me
that's not a bad way though because at
this point I mean I know I'm going to
see it i am actually excited and hopeful
for it based off the trailers that have
already come out to this point this
trailer I didn't feel like it gave me
anything new but it reinforced all the
stuff that I already knew I was looking
forward to and it didn't it didn't do
what and say late the trailers for like
x-men apocalypse did which was ruin a
bunch of crap that happens late in the
movie so they're managing to maintain
and keep reemphasize the stuff that
intrigues me they're not ruining
anything that happens later solid work
moving on pirates of the caribbean dead
men tell no tales now I love the first
pirates of the caribbean I enjoy the
fact when I actually think the third one
is a lot better than people give it
credit for the fourth one was not good
and that's what I really tired of the
formula of these things specifically in
terms of Jack Sparrow seems to have no
new adventures everything we see it's in
dealing with the consequences of
adventures we never actually saw him go
on you know he had some black beard knew
who was they had had some sort of back
and forth at some point there's
obviously a ton of history with him and
Davy Jones and all those other like can
we just have something that's like him
now you know and that and just more
immortal evil pirate summer i'm just i'm
tired of it but that said if i if i take
the baggage out of that look at it in
the vacuum the look of these pirates and
they're so they're walking and and
they're just on deck but like javier
bardem this hair is flowing like you
still are that's a cool book i like that
i like the fact that Jack himself only
shows up at the very end on a trailer
like kind of this what it's like in the
movie like maybe it can be mostly about
people tracking him down and he only
shows up at the end we got a glimpse of
Orlando Bloom Kelly Michael journal I'm
fine with that so I'm like if I remove
the baggage of the series i'm looking at
it going yeah maybe but then i remember
the baggage I'm like I don't know next
up fate of the furious now I actually
have not seen any film and The Fast and
the Furious franchise but you know what
watching this trailer I kind of wish I
had because i watch this and what that
looks awesome I mean it looks stupid and
insane but awesomely stupid and insane
and I kind of wish I was in on this I'm
like I don't feel I I mean this is
obviously banking on a lot of
established relationships between
characters at this point I feel like I
can't jump in at this point I'm not sure
I have the energy to start from the
beginning especially since most people
seem to agree didn't really get good
till four or five but even going back
that far I don't find the the time or
the energy to catch up as much as I need
you to get full appreciate appreciation
out of the things but kind of wish I did
have the time and the basis to do it
because this looks really cool I hope
I'm going to see it but that's only
because I in the other one maybe I can
find the time to catch up I don't know
looks cool though looks fun rolling in
with the other trailer to feature Dwayne
the rock Johnson Baywatch which looks
finally it's very clearly cut from the
exact same mold as 21 Jump Street on
there are a couple decent jokes in is I
like the performers that is not the kind
of movie it's the kind of movie I'm
liable to catch on netflix later as
opposed to recommend to the theater and
see I wasn't that I got one really good
laugh out of this trailer and that was
just Zac Efron's response what are you
wearing freedom that was funny and I
saved my favorite for last my favorite
trailer stranger things season two I
haven't talked about stranger things but
it's because as with most sort of
streaming shows I don't I don't binge
through them fast enough that so by the
time I'm done I feel like everyone's you
know already said their piece in terms
of you know YouTube or written articles
or you know I feel like although all the
word is out and there's I unless I have
an opinion that is distinctly different
from what the majority is I feel like
there's nothing for me to add
so I didn't talk about the first season
aphasia things but i love the first
season of change of thing that i am so
looking at me this thing held me on the
first publicity image which was those
kids in Ghostbusters uniforms
Ghostbusters is my favorite movie of all
time these kids saw a ghost busters they
love those buses I love these kids and I
love the sense of escalation that shot
with just a cute thing like in the
clouds and it's already but what is that
I don't know but that is a perfect
scaling up from the demagogue install
the musical just a few little bits of
that's the music that D music is so
awesome and it's going to be a really
long way to this stuff comes what
September oh god I want it now so
there's my thoughts on the trailers that
we got during the Super Bowl did you
watch the super bowl or did you catch
the trailers like me online after the
game was over whichever was the case
what was your favorite what was your
least favorite what sold you on
something you didn't think you were
interested in what killed your interest
whatever your thoughts were on any of
these drops coming down in the comments
let's talk about don't forget to Like
subscribe hit that little bell so you
get notifications follow me on twitter
at council of geeks check out the count
for each podcast available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is cure